Hi there. I'd like to show you some improvements we've just released to Burp Suite Enterprise
Edition. It's almost two years since we launched Enterprise Edition, and in that time we've
been working hard to build the product. In today's update, we have some nice UI improvements
and an awesome new single sign-on feature. Let's take a look.
The first thing you'll notice is that there's a nice new header. This makes it faster to
navigate. You can get straight to filtered views for sites, scans, and teams, and straight
to key functions like creating a new site or a new scan.
Within the Sites menu, there's a new Sites with Issues filter. This takes you straight to the
Sites page with that filter applied, so you can quickly find where your vulnerabilities
are. There's a new Settings menu where all of the usual settings live, and there's a
new User menu where you can configure your own account.
The page for creating a new site has been redesigned with a nicer UI. You now only need to provide
a single URL for each site because Burp will scan everything beneath that URL by default.
You can still expose the old settings where you can provide multiple URLs for a site if you
need to. There's a new Protocol Settings option where you can configure whether to scan both
and the other URLs for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the
same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for
the site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site.
You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the
same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site.
new URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can
use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site.
You can also use the same URL for a site. You can also use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site.
You can also use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site.
You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site.
You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site. You can use the same URL for a site.
We'll have recorded logins. This means if your application uses a complex login sequence, not just a username and password,
you'll be able to record that sequence using your browser and load it into Enterprise Edition to use during scans.
And for the first time in Enterprise Edition, we'll support Burp Suite extensions. You'll be able to load these from the BAP store or your own custom extensions, just like you can in Burp Suite Pro.
Anyway, we really hope you enjoyed today's release. And as always, do let us have any feedback.
Thank you.